if you've been watching the Whitehouse
coronavirus press briefings you probably
realize by now that it is all coming off
the walls and the world mental health
coalition is now urging Donald Trump to
resign over being as they say severely
mentally troubled in the middle of a
pandemic the corona virus pandemic which
is leading to increasingly horrifying
numbers of deaths here in the United
States the White House meant I'm sorry
the the world mental health coalition
posted a prescription for survival where
they point out that they've been warning
about Trump since 2017 they've had
countless psychiatrists point out the
dangers of Donald Trump in a position of
power on countless issues and now with
the corona virus pandemic spreading and
Trump completely on the wrong side of
just about every element of it while
increasingly belligerent in his
delusions of grandeur the way the World
Mental Health coalition now outlines a
prescription for what they believe
should happen and this includes some
combination of using the 25th amendment
to remove Trump a new impeachment
attempt on the basis of his mishandling
of coronavirus Trump straight up
resigning a court-ordered mental health
eval or the removal of his
decision-making ability on coronavirus
as well as the suspension of the White
House press briefings themselves
suggesting that it should really be the
CDC doing these briefings without
political interference which I agree
with now unfortunately none of these
things are going to happen Donald
Trump's cabinet is not going to invoke
the 25th amendment on Trump they're just
not it's a to even dream of a different
outcome is simply not based in reality
impeaching Trump over this even if the
House impeached Trump over his
coronavirus response it's not gonna
happen in the Senate so that isn't going
to be happening Trump is obviously not
going to resign the presidency there
will of course be no mental health
evaluation for
on Donald Trump and nobody's going to
remove Trump's decision-making power on
the virus as far as Trump stopped
stopping the press briefings good luck
Trump yesterday for example wasn't even
scheduled to do a press briefing but
told people around him hey it's free TV
and they get good ratings so that is not
something that is going to change Trump
can't do rallies right now because of
social distancing so he's doing the
press briefings instead so we have a
situation where the United States is
39th in the world in per capita testing
not first as Donald Trump has now
claimed multiple times the u.s. response
was slow it was wrongheaded on many
fronts which we've outlined to you daily
Trump is spreading disinformation like
it'll go away like a miracle in April we
have 15 cases and we will soon have zero
sometimes a scarf is more effective than
a mask and on and on and on but in the
midst of all of this the only
opportunity to remove Donald Trump is in
November by voting him out and that is
something he is going to make as
difficult as possible for people to do
now of course I'm not arguing that the
World Mental Health coalition is wrong
of course they are right
Trump's presidency has become deadly on
this issue as if it wasn't already
deadly before on a number of different
issues but expecting any of these
suggestions you know resident 25th
amendment resignation forcing a mental
health evaluation on Trump it's just not
gonna happen so let's focus our energy
on to things that we know work what do
we know works social distancing works
now unfortunately more and more
right-wing churchgoers are not only
ignoring social distancing they are
scofflaws when it comes to it they are
deliberately doing the exact opposite
we'll get to that later in the show but
social distancing works and we should be
doing it number two voting Trump out in
November you don't need to convince
Trump's cabinet to invoke any amendment
you don't need to force anything on you
just vote him out okay so he is not
going to be removed by
any of these other means that I've
mentioned let's do what we can social
distance now remove Trump in November